catherine if i may i want to pull the
audience for a second just so we can
create a profile of who all these folks
are
so let me ask you guys let's take a show
of hands how many of you are
undergraduates
okay
uh well at stanford that just means
you're gonna start your company three
years earlier right you're gonna
uh how about graduate students
people are out working in the uh in the
real world
next
how many of you have ever worked in a
startup
okay that's pretty impressive
how many of you have ever founded a
startup
and uh
apropos of today's conversation how many
of you
intend at some point in your career to
be either an angel investor or a venture
capitalist
i'll be calling all of you soon
okay now we know who we're talking okay
so
how did you get into venture capital you
you say you had a crazy
path to silicon valley give me a little
hit yeah okay you guys got to hear this
i mean the first 10 years of my life was
pretty random and uh my business life
and
i saw if any of you undergrads think you
might kind of suck at career planning or
don't have a career plan
listen to this if i can do it you can do
it so
um
where were you born i was born in l.a
um but went to school at university of
toronto because i'm about
weather so
anyway so um
yeah so i'll just run through this real
quick cause it's so crazy um
so
raised in l.a uh and
this violin playing thing has been a
lifelong thing with me so i studied
music at usc starting before i was in
college and so then when i decided to
major in physics like i didn't think to
change so i went to usc
um briefly and um caltech didn't take
women back in the late 60s so i would
love to have gone to caltech but that
didn't work out so
um
anyway so but i had a boyfriend at
caltech so i got to use their computer
so i bootleg time on their cdc 6600 and
i literally learned to program fortran
out of the trash can there i pick up
listings study them and that's why i
learned fortran anyway
but then i went to university of toronto
um and majored in physics at a real
science and engineering school and that
was good
and i also wrote a bunch of 4chan
programs there for their ibm 368 was
writing curve fitting routines back then
and uh
anyway so bs in physics and then i just
i thought i wanted to go on for a phd in
physics but i had an opportunity to be
an intern at argonne lab and in chicago
and so i took that
and
got more free programming time on
mini computers and wrote a bunch of
simulations for quantum mechanical
processes and stuff like that but more
importantly
i figured out after a year doing that
that i didn't want to be a physicist so
so i went and got an engineering job in
chicago so i started in engineering at a
big company chicago bill and howell
which is no longer in existence um
and then i realized that i didn't know
anything about accounting and all that
business jazz so i went off to
university of chicago and got an mba
um then moved to another big company in
chicago so finally so like and i love
computers this whole time and i was
really thinking what am i doing here i
really really should be in the computer
business but i'm kind of glad i didn't
jump too early because if i had i would
have ended up in boston at a mini
computer company and that's not where i
wanted to be so when the microprocessor
got invented
that's when i got really anxious and
finally
came out here
so it was the
it was the 8008 that convinced you to
move to silicon valley
actually the truth is more like the z80
but
still federation yeah really so uh so
when personal computers started
happening that's when i said okay they
can't do this without me i got to be out
there so so i left and by then of course
i'd had kind of a big job there so my
ceo
at the large company i left was like you
can't leave you're the highest ranking
woman in the company i was a division
marketing manager so anyway so it was a
little bit hard to leave but not that
hard so i came out here
and joined um my first startup
well i didn't know what i was doing so i
interviewed at tandem and apple and
intel those were the kind of big
companies back then
but i said heck you know i really want
to do a startup so i'm not going to join
one of those so i ended up with this
weird logic of
joining the smallest company that made
me an offer i decided that's what i was
going to do and so i joined this company
called data systems design i don't know
if you know this and yeah
all gone yeah and they made pdp 11
peripherals back in the day this is like
1980. and um
one of the cool things is that
one of our customers was larry ellison
who was writing oracle and pdp 11
assembler in a little sweet op-ed
sandhill road and so i went to meet
larry and uh somewhere along the line
and i was like oh i got to be at oracle
and here's where
chance favors the prepared minds one of
my favorite sayings because all those
years that i sort of wasted at big
companies i did develop a perspective of
what big companies needed and when i saw
this product i was like
this is going to change the world the
big company data world and i got to be
there well you know that's always been
the debate whether you should go work
for a big company for a while and get
perspective or
go start in a small company and escape
all the damage that a big company does
to you yeah right big debate right now
and um where do you come down on it well
in my day
and and in my career in the 40 years
since then i've always advised young
people to like go get a job at intel or
oracle or google or some good place
that's going to teach you some stuff and
then go start a company
i'm not so sure that's the right advice
now
the advice i still have now though is
whatever you do make sure you're
learning from really really smart people
um but the big company thing i don't
know it's changing so fast but for me it
was great to have the perspective
of what big companies need as far as
software and data networking and all the
stuff i made all that money in the
venture capital business was in part
informed by the the market the end user
view i had from my eight years at big
companies so your second employer in the
valley was oracle yes sir how many
people were there
like 15 but i wasn't employed number 15
because larry had gone through a few
people so yeah it was probably more like
i don't know 25-ish
do you have any sense it was going to be
oracle
yes i did even though
our sales numbers back then were one
million three million five million and
12 million so that's not like that's
good but it's not like off the charts
that was 81 82 or 384
and then after the 12 million it doubled
every year for a long time um and the
reason how the sensor was going to be
oracle was firstly caleri is truly the
best entrepreneur i've ever met the man
is amazing okay i was going to ask you
about that because i mean he obviously
has a very unique reputation
yeah
yeah now one of them is oracle
when it was going full bore was an
absolute insane pressure cooker i mean
the joke always was the first year
you're there you think you've landed the
best job in the world the second year
you're there you begin to wonder what's
wrong with you and the third year you're
in intensive therapy
what did was it like that when you were
there
i don't think quite that larry was still
uh yeah getting his style organized and
so i remember a side of larry that i
don't think he lets show very often
nowadays but
he loved to laugh he had a huge sense of
humor we spent oh if we weren't yelling
at each other we were laughing and so
it was a very funny but intense time and
there was also some i mean the term
spitting mad i actually have seen that
and so
but the important thing about oracle as
a business was
with this little dinky thing in this
little tiny suite in sand hill and the
phone was ringing all the time people
were really interested in what we had
and they were like
we couldn't wait to get the product and
of course you know there was a lot of
bugs to fix and it was like not an easy
product to build so what did you learn
about working for a company growing that
fast i mean there's really not
much that gets taught
about being in a
comet-like startup where it's doubling
in size every six months or three months
right and none of us had ever done it
before either there was nobody to go ask
yeah
well there was
there was don lucas upstairs from us who
actually invested like 50k or something
i don't know and uh so so he was kind of
some gray hair around there but
uh it was just
breathless and all that mattered to
larry rightly so i think back then was
engineering and sales like marketing
what i did didn't matter which is why i
had a sales quota
so i did the oem sales and that was fine
and and that's why i really learned to
sell
very important so all you engineers out
there
if you're gonna do startups make sure
you learn how to sell really important
and and i know my son's an engineer so i
know that engineers are like what i
don't want to sell i don't like salesmen
get over that
now there's another aspect of larry's
reputation
that i want to bring up you and i had
lunch one day with pat house who was
just a counterpart of yours at oracle
and i asked both of you and she went on
of course to be ceo of siebel systems
and all that and i said
i don't understand how too strong women
like two of you
could work at a place for larry ellison
and you guys took great umbrage at that
you almost yelled at me over the table
why i mean he does have a certain
occupation i still can't remember what i
said there but you said because he's a
damn good uh he's the world's greatest
expert on database management yeah and a
great entrepreneur larry is an amazing
guy and he is he is agnostic as far as i
can tell about women i mean he look at
staff for cats nowadays
and um
uh so he doesn't care who you are what
you are as long as you're great at what
you do
and so you know i'm a defender flareon
so how long are you at oracle i was only
there for three years
and that was your last real job
it was the last time you ever worked for
him it was did you have like some
epiphany
alongside the bay underneath you know
the emerald towers and uh you just said
i don't want to work for anybody anymore
uh
sort of but my epiphany was that i got
fired oh that'll do it
larry used to express
extreme displeasure by firing people and
um he would i think i'd probably been
fired a couple times before but it was
and i didn't pay attention to
it but but this time he really fired me
and like i i didn't get hired back until
after lunch
and
uh and so he really meant it and i
thought
that sucks i'm not doing that
anymore so i think the term nowadays is
you incorporated i decided oh sorry um i
wasn't gonna do that anymore and so i
quit i i stayed there for a few more
months but i was grumpy and i quit
and that's what happened and then but
then i was like
geez i don't want to work for a startup
that
that you know that's not as good as
oracle and
believe me there wasn't another company
as good as oracle at the time so i was
like oh i got to think something up and
so
let me ask one quick question because i
don't think this ever gets addressed
either what do you do on the morning
after
you quit a place like oracle where you
have no job prospects yet you don't know
exactly what you're getting well one of
them wasn't that bad go ahead
i had lots of job prospects people were
calling me about startups that sucked i
mean by then this was 1984. so there was
some venture capital there was a few
companies starting so it wasn't that
other than apple though it was kind of a
ugly startup era
i you know and like bill cross at 3-com
was talking to me about being marketing
vp of three con that would have been
legit right but i i didn't i didn't want
to do that so
um
anyway so i've i got kind of this is
another like crazy career move i thought
well heck i'll just be an executive
recruiter because i was getting called
by all these recruiters i'm thinking
they're having more fun than i'm having
so
um
so i started an executive search firm
which
um seems really crazy but my plan
was that it was going to be a temporary
thing it'd be like a cool way to look
for an another startup and i thought i'd
maybe do it for a year
but um
it turned out i did it for five years uh
and i really loved it although five
years was enough um so i started
recruiting people like me other
marketing vps but then i branched into
sales vps and engineering vps and then
pretty soon i started getting
called to do searches for ceos for
venture capital firms and so i did all
that stuff and had a baby true for you
ladies
it was on my mind when i did this was
also oh i could have that baby which is
like getting kind of late in the day for
me so
um i did that and and i to this day
don't know how you can have a baby and
do a real start-up uh no clue so i
couldn't so i did it that way and it was
great so i got caught by baby who's now
27 years old yeah but uh and doing what
and and he's a mechanical engineer
having a great time
um
anyway so
yeah so the recruiting thing turned out
to be a really interesting career move
i'm not recommending it but i'm just
saying
do interesting stuff you know
so how'd you become a vc
yeah so you know most people that want
to be a vc find it really hard to get
into the business but um most people
even very successful people go in and
fail
we've seen a lot of well-known silicon
valley figures over the last 30 years
become vcs and just doesn't work for
them why did it work for you
yeah good question um
well i think part of it was actually
over the five years that i was a
recruiter i literally worked with 80
different companies and um
and
i was a retrained recruiter so i had to
like i'd like
strap my body to these companies and if
it if it sucked and didn't work i
couldn't like get somebody to join them
so i had learned to be very careful
about who i took on as a client
which meant i had to understand the
market they had to have a market
opportunity that made sense where i
could recruit a superstar to join them
and so i learned a lot about
what kind of market opportunity makes
sense i i watch these companies in
various stages of success or disarray
and like you know anytime you're
recruiting a ceo there's probably
something going on so
um i learned a fair amount about
what can go right what can go wrong and
and so and in five years i saw 80
companies a venture capitalist doesn't
get to do that vc might invest in i
don't know two three four companies a
year so it takes a lot of years before
they can see all that stuff up close so
you weren't just filling job slots you
were actually studying business plans
and doing due diligence i kind of was
because i didn't take i had more
business coming at me than i could
handle so i would like try to figure out
which was the best one
and uh
what i only worked on three searches at
a time and so yeah so i i had so part of
the reason i was successful was
that um i had all that perspective
and i guess
i don't know what i think you have an
aptitude for it uh maybe yeah what in
your personality makes you a good
vc ah good question
i really
like digging into people
and i got pretty good at it and so i i
like to understand what makes people
take them and what makes them motivated
and so there's that whole side of it the
other side of it is like physics is a
dangerous major because you know a
little bit about everything and nobody's
too sure what you don't know and so
and so
i was able to always like figure out if
the technology made some kind of sense
if it was like doable by human beings
and all that kind of stuff
and also i think
really good venture capital is a
craftsmanship job and i'm i'm a musician
and a painter and that's that i'm kind
of craftsmanship matters to me
well we get to the other great question
then the debate has always been do you
invest in the team are you at john doerr
school of investing in the team or you
do you invest in the price
i am hardcore market opportunity
investor so even though i love people
and i had a lot of that you know
experience with the recruiting stuff
um if if if you have a great market
opportunity you can get great people and
if you have a sucky market opportunity
you can't and so
uh
i and so the popular term is pivot these
days i think that's way easier said than
done um
so thinking oh well if this doesn't work
i can pivot
i think it's a little bit wacky and so
um definitely a market opportunity
investor and so of all the companies i
did
in my venture capital career
um i only broke that rule a couple of
times and
i should say i only had two
failures we'll come back to that but one
of them
interestingly enough was steve blank and
rocket science games those
of you who know steve know this story
and i know steve's in london right now
so i can say this so
so steve used to
um ask me he was going like
so we're up aren't you gonna
fire me
i'm like steve believe me i would if i
thought it would make any difference but
this market sucks and there ain't
nothing we can do about it and so you
know and you're still friends with him
all these years oh god we've known each
other for 35 years we were counting it
up the other day so
anyway it was kind of unusual that says
something about you as well and about
steve yeah well a lot of us it's like
we're both still alive yeah don't hold
any grudges
oh no no it was a learning experience
for both of us but but anyway yeah i'm a
marketer tell me about some of the early
companies you invest in
and if you have any anecdotes about it
yeah um i could talk for hours about
these we probably don't want to get too
carried away but like
the list is uh
you may not know a lot of these
companies but um documentum
which i invested in the early 90s which
is to this day of very much a living
product although went public and then
got acquired um interwoven um
grand junction networks
applied digital access primary access to
um
telecom companies
so i did a lot of telecom networking and
enterprise software that was the kind of
stuff that was good in my era
and but your ratio was astounding
and i think you attributed to the fact
that you never accepted that standard vc
ratio of two winners out of ten yeah
four oh yeah four struggle along and it
really irritates me when vc say oh yeah
you know well there's gonna be one out
of ten deals there's gonna be one winner
you know two or three also rants and the
rest are write-offs i never played that
game never even thought about it
my idea was that everyone had to be a
winner
and um
and so i and that this market
opportunity thing i only went into it if
i was convinced that it was going to be
a winner i didn't get it right all the
time but uh
and
if a company was starting to fail i
worked my butt off to not let that
happen even if i ended up with like two
or three times my money
there's a pride thing for me and a and a
life thing for the entrepreneurs whose
life was on the line for a few years
there and so i just i i think a lot of
investors don't think about the lives of
the people they're investing in well yes
yeah i don't take failure kindly so
i could tell one war story if we're not
a near-death experience yeah a bunch of
my companies that turned out very
successful had near-death experiences
like so you started people get ready for
this it's like not so easy so
um i'll just tell grandchildren network
story so this company made the first
ether 100 megabit ethernet switch back
in the early 90s
and they were a bunch of guys from three
com incredibly talented guys
and um
and for me the scariest part of any
startup is okay you're done with the
engineering and you put the product out
on the market and they don't beat a path
to your doors like nobody does anything
and it's horrible which is why steve
blank does his thing but we'll come back
to that anyway so
so we introduced our product nobody
bought it and these guys were three com
guys so they were used to indirect
distribution channels so they signed up
a bunch of distributors and dealers and
stuff like that well they those kind of
channels can't deal with a completely
new technology this has to be sold
direct and i couldn't convince them of
that
because they were three column guys and
so i said okay uh
here's the deal we'll do it your way i
can't remember whether it was i said for
six months or until we only have 500k in
cash left but i said i set an end point
because i knew it wasn't going to work
but i knew this product was going to
work
in the market so
so they kind of ran out of time nobody
had bought hardly anything and but in
the background i was recruiting a
a
direct sales force a bunch of um
sales reps there were some good ones
available at the time so when they hit
my day i said okay here we go i've got
these five guys we're going to go sell
direct now they go well okay but
we don't think it'll work and then it
just completely took off and it like
quadrupled in sales every month and then
it got to be like doubling in sales
every month until the numbers got huge
and um
and and then we had an interesting
debate whether to go public or sell to
cisco for a pretty nice price and that
by the way grand junction networks
as well as documentary both stanford
business school cases i don't know if
you guys still study that stuff but um
so it was the sell the cisco versus
go public that's the case but the more
interesting case to me is the what
happened in the distribution channels
anyway so that company's now worth
billions of dollars and the seed of the
whole um
uh ethernet switching business at cisco
came from these guys
and i just saw we just had a 20-year
reunion
and got together out in colorado and
reminisced about all this jazz and six
out of the seven people around the table
were pilots which that was pretty cool
but plus you
yeah yeah
uh now you were a pioneer of micro
venture capital firms
you uh according to the records uh
floodgate peshmergan mar engineering
capital
want to tell me about them yeah are they
are they alike are they different
they're
pretty different so um yeah so i
helped mike maples start um
floodgate back in we we dreamed it up in
07 but i think we raised the money in
0.8
and um
and at the time the whole idea of the
craftsmanship in early stage it was
partly the economics that was now
possible to start a company with a lot
less money than before so you didn't
need to go raise 10 million bucks right
out of the shoot but the other side of
it was
um
there's a good deal of craftsmanship
involved in this and mike has that skill
set and so
um so we started found floodgate in uh
08 and he's on his i think his fifth
fund now and i'm an investor in all
these funds and i still coach those guys
pretty often and then pedgemen mar
i worked with those
guys to get started
and help them bring in some investors
and and i can coach them now and then
and then engineering capital uh we just
closed today um and ashmitsudan is the
founder and they do uh ashley's going to
do enterprise infrastructure software so
whereas pedromar does
and floodgate both do a fair amount of
consumer stuff as well as enterprise so
kind of a mix
and uh interestingly enough
both floodgate and um
patron mar
have
there she is a woman um
each of them has a woman
a partner who is also a phd in some hard
stuff at stanford which is amazing so
anyway now was there a moment
when i think in everybody's career if
they're pursuing a particular direction
there's a moment when they realize
they're they're good at this that this
is what you were destined to do did you
have that moment yeah i think kind of by
like
i had been in the business maybe three
or four years when i started and my
companies were just cooking um
yeah i was starting to think this is
gonna work out
and uh but
i knew that like
uh a couple years before the outside
world knew that
um but then it all happened because i
mean once you get the market opportunity
right and the execution is right you
can't hardly stop it so okay you've said
it's not the calls you take it's the
calls you make in life too is that your
life motto
well what does it mean first of all
this is my little saying that i love um
i don't know if people even make calls
anymore don't you guys like tweet and
stuff like that but anyway and what it
means is this when you're out in in the
real world there is
both in startups and venture capital but
for sure venture capital so much stuff
is coming at you you're just like
overwhelmed you can stay very insanely
busy just responding to the stuff that
comes to you and what that saying means
to me is don't do that
make sure that you keep in your mind
your agenda your goals what matters to
you and what kind of moves the state of
the art forward and make sure that every
week you at least work a little bit on
those things that matter to you
and rather than just like deal with all
the that's coming your way which is
always a lot
and i think in the venture capital
context um if you look at most of my
really great startups they weren't guys
that called me i called them i found
them
and
that's pretty huge
yeah i mean you talk about the
importance of cold calls but cold
calling is like antithetical to the
engineering personality
yeah and there's always been this
dimension in what you talk about of
having to do
the ugly business side of things it's
not just designing products it's not
just chasing a market it's actually
doing the blocking and tackling of real
business all the way right yeah
designing products is really fun and
there's hardly anything we can't build
in silicon valley these days but
like i don't here again i don't know if
you guys do cold calls but i used to
love it because like you get through the
secretary and then you get to talk to
the guy it's usually a guy and he got
like 12 seconds to grab his attention
i've found the adrenaline of that really
interesting and so and i sort of i of
course learned that in the recruiting
business but it turns out to be really
useful in
life too you know like when you're
selling stuff so
um
yeah
and i don't know
i i went through a phase in my early 20s
where i was a physicist and i couldn't
be bothered with all that other stuff
but you know what
nothing happens if you don't make it
happen
so let's talk about the venture capital
industry now because you're still deeply
deeply involved in fact you're down in
town more often now than you were 10
years ago it seems like yeah so how's it
changed
man well everything changes in the
valley all the time so um
you know at first there was this thing
in the early 2000s where um
the the normal venture firm economics
kind of didn't make so much sense
because you could start a lot of really
great companies on not very much money
and the angel investors were doing a lot
of that and then that which is why the
micro vc started
um
and so so there's this whole bifurcation
now the venture business between micro
vcs
and and the larger firms but then
there's also there are like the v cs
like andreessen horowitz huge firms that
do a lot of late stage investing and
we'll come back to that and some of the
um kind of middle-sized firms that were
pretty much the model of
venture capital in my day
um but i think
right now the bifurcation is micro vcs
and and huge firms
um
they talk about they talk about the
chasm between
uh angel and series a that for all the
money you read about in these gigantic
funds there's hundreds of companies
sitting out there right at the edge
they're running out of money from angels
and they can't make that jump to series
a because it's just hard to do and
harder than ever well there's a lot of
money out there
you do you have to have a market
opportunity that makes sense
um
and uh
uh
so i think if you can't raise money in
this environment you probably have to
ask yourself is your
is your market really all that
interesting yeah
uh you also have pointed out that ipos
seem to take a lot longer than they used
yeah man in my day in like the 90s and
kind of culminating with 2000
um you could get a company my average
was kind of between four and seven years
of life would be when you could expect
an ipo or a liquidity event and uh
that just doesn't happen now companies
have to be much larger and
you know
much more sustainable
and i actually think that's really
healthy because you know
i lived through the 2000
crash and um
in a way you know
individual investors got hurt in that
market at least now does it crash now as
professional investors are going to get
hurt i think that's better but um
uh
but
what's
working for the super vcs right now is
that
companies are are required to have much
more revenue and much more reality to
them before they go public so all the
money that used to be raised in the
public market is in fact being
invested by by the later stage venture
capitalists and i actually think it's a
very healthy system well we saw ipos
disappear basically in the first place
by the end of the first decade of this
century and now they they're coming back
but m a is still awfully strong around
here i mean i can remember 2000 every
business plan had an ipo as a
liquidation event by 2006 or seven it
was the last line was and then we'll
sell to google
and then in 2012 it's then we'll sell to
facebook yeah um
how is that ratio swinging these days
well true i think the bar to go public
is very high now um but i think
so you know
in my venture capital career
i i made more money selling companies
and taken them public i i think it's a
great route um
for liquidity and a great
route for the people and let me tell you
it sucks being on the board of a public
company so there's that um
so i think that's very healthy for you
entrepreneurs though i think the trick
is
to keep enough to
until you know a little more about what
the outcome is going to be keep your
runway clear so that you don't raise too
so much money that you can't sell
at a modest price and be happy
um
you know so it's a it's it's tempting to
go raise too much money and then you get
yourself in a spot where
you know nobody's happy if you don't
sell for 500 million dollars and those
kind of deals are rare so whereas if you
can sell for like 80
that could be really nice if you only
raised a million bucks so
you got to think about that and we've
been talking about all the changes of
venture capital what stayed the same
i mean you you have a long history now
you can look at different generations of
venture capitalists yeah well
um what stayed the same for startup
people is it's still about the market
opportunity
um
uh when you raise venture capital it's
really important to get a great venture
capitalist on your board somebody who
will like kind of live and die the way i
did about whether you succeed or not who
not just view you as a transaction but a
part of their life that they're going to
make successful
get that it's really important for you
and there are guys out there that can do
that and and women um
uh and so i i would say be very
particular about who your investors are
and um and it's not always about price i
would any day recommend taking a great
venture capitalist at a lower price than
some
person at a ridiculously high price so
get you know get your
company funding set and then later
when things are going well you can go
raise money at crazy prices and get
crazy people involved that's okay but
not until you've built your foundation
you've got a few minutes let's dwell
down into the process of being a venture
capitalist for example you talked about
the primacy of market opportunity what
does that mean what do you look for
in a great market opportunity
yeah so here's what i always say i say
i'm looking for
um a target customer with the compelling
reason to buy now that seems like a
simple thing to say but there it's
fraught like target customer
i should back up one second i did only
b2b i didn't do consumer we can come
back to that
but target customer means a target to
bulk customer like you have to figure
out kind of who they are where they are
how are you going to reach them that you
have to have a way to reach them they
have to have certain characteristics
and um
and if you can kind of figure all that
out that will tell you what your kind of
sales and marketing strategy needs to be
this is a little bit like what steve
blank teaches um and the compelling
reason to buy is
uh
the product needs to be so good
or so compelling to them anyway that
that they'll kind of do anything to get
it like deal with a lot of bugs stuff
that doesn't work right um
pay you some advanced money to continue
the development i've had lots of crazy
stories like that but they have to be
really compelled and compelling usually
means a revenue enhancer
not just a cost reduction cost
reductions are fine but something that
gets them more revenue faster is uh
really compelling
and um now what if there's a company
already in that market an incumbent
company
yeah should i keep you out yeah this is
something i learned over all these years
in the vet business we all would always
worry about the incumbent whoever had
like a similar product in the market
that was a large company
man it's very rare that a startup gets
beat by a large company um
mostly they get beat by some other
startup down the street who's smarter
than they are so i i would spend time
looking at my
competitors my startup competitors not
the big companies they just they don't
have the attitude we do now looking out
over your career it seems to me you
favor b2b over consumer why is that yeah
um
so this target customer compelling
reason to buy thing is um it's a
rational process
and um so so you can like go do homework
you can do steve blank's lean startup
thing and go talk to a bunch of target
customers
and
it's fairly logical
whereas consumer
to me has there's always been like an
element of luck
in in it and it's like it's great fun
when it works but you know it doesn't
work all the time and so
um
and
i want to do the kind of numbers i
did in the venture business not some
random stuff and um so consumer doesn't
work with kind of my way of thinking i
think consumer stuff is very cool but uh
i i i don't have the guts for it and so
so
when i sometimes when i come to stanford
i hear people talking about all these
consumer ideas and
you know it it looks easy but it's not
so you have to also ask yourself if
you're a lucky person i think i you know
um i don't i don't think it's for
everybody so i'd encourage you if you're
not so sure you're a lucky person maybe
think about some b2b stuff
let's talk about the ceo now how do you
how do you find a good ceo what do you
look for
you know it's it boils down to pretty
simple stuff but hard to find um i look
for a ceo who's a
a great leader
there's one of them sitting in the back
right now
and um
and also who's the best salesman in the
company uh that like if they if you get
that ceo in front of a customer they're
going to buy this stuff
and and that doesn't mean that the ceo
had to come up through sales i've had
great salesmen who were engineers or
marketing people and and so it doesn't
kind of matter where they came from but
they have to be a great salesman
and enough adjust to the customers but
also
to recruit people into the company to
get venture capitalists to invest it's
really
you've crucial
talked about keeping them aligned they
have to the a great ceo has to keep
everybody going that's yeah that's the
leadership thing because the startups
that fail often have like everybody's
mad at each other and they're all going
off doing in different directions and
it's all crazy it's really important
that the whole team is pushing in the
same direction kind of has the same
vision
kind of knows what the plan is knows who
the competitors are and and that's comes
from leadership i've also noticed a lot
of really good ceos actually know when
to stop people that that startups have a
tendency to just keep designing stuff
they keep having really great ideas and
if the ceo doesn't say okay we're going
to do this one
they never do they just go on forever
yeah then that's that's also a job of a
good venture capitalist too i mean yes
yeah
um
not to bring up larry ellison again but
you said he you said he was an
interesting leader because he had
periods of enormous almost superhuman
intensity and then periods of abdication
yeah what does that mean we weren't sure
what it meant
we used to talk about that
um
larry you would do his thing
but then every i don't know a couple of
months he disappeared for three or four
days
maybe a week and we didn't know where he
was
a few people get emails from
but i think he was he was thinking stuff
up so larry was that rare case of a guy
who had was pretty incredible on
execution
but also kind of had the the technology
strategy in his head and the the
business strategy and so he used to like
go away and think i think and uh we were
never too sure what i was doing but but
i know he would come back from these
things
with all these ideas that well the thing
you were talking about he would have
like 50 ideas and then we'd all go dump
on all those ideas and we'd hone him
down but you often he would come back
there was a nugget in there and so i
think that's what he was doing that
an interesting case and i don't think
that's sort of normal for a ceo but work
for larry let's talk about life and
being a ceo i'll give you an act of my
own i was interviewing scott mcneely
from my pbs series
and we got talking and i asked a
question i said
you've got little kids at home
how do you balance
having a family with running a fortune
100 company god what do you say he got
this terrified look in his eyes and he
said
i can't
i just can't and the pr person ran onto
the set grabbed him and said mr mcneely
has to go and he took him off
and ended the end of the recording
because well because you can't allow the
ceo of a company that size to show human
weakness right not in the public eye
so you have said
if you're trying to find
a work-life balance as a startup ceo
forget it
oh yeah i'd say that's right um
yeah people talk about this balance
thing but like i never figured it out i
literally had to start my recruiting
firm to have a baby i couldn't figure it
out um
venture capital is way easier than a
startup so like i could sort of do that
but um
you can't do it i don't think and do a
great job you can do a social job but
it's also a job and a startup will get
you killed so
um
i think
like i quit playing violin for five
years
i was doing startups that's how bad it
was for me um
so i think uh you've got to
be ready to really put everything into
it and like um
and one of my which reminds me of an
anecdote because martin bronze is
sitting in the back so when one night i
used to do my best worrying at night
because i didn't have time during the
day and so i was
i was sitting there thinking
trying to sleep thinking about some i
can't it was some dumb pricing issue or
something at interwoven and i and i had
it all figured out so i i call up uh
martin's voicemail this back in the day
of voicemail but i would leave him this
big long dump because it was like too
long to type so i call him up it's like
3 30 in the morning he answers the
freaking phone
and i'm going what are you doing
he goes i'm working what are you doing
i'm like we got to talk
and you know that's the kind of life
that you've that well venture
capitalists maybe don't always have to
live like that but ceos do so
don't think too much about balance
what advice do you have for someone
starting a company today and i'll give
you i'll give you the first one which is
you've said listen to steve blank yeah
well i i presume a bunch of you guys
have heard steve blank's
stuff but uh the whole i know
who we're talking about hands you guys
all know steve blink right good yes yeah
he does a great job so um
so this thing i was saying about uh
the
back in the old days the day you got
your product all done
and you put it out there on the market
it's the most scary day for me because
nobody buys it and then you have to go
actually figure out what the hell you're
doing so what steve has invented is a
methodology for um kind of figuring
getting to that spot way earlier before
you spent all the money and built maybe
the wrong product um and so
take his lean startup thing seriously
figure out what your market is and how
it works and who are the target
customers and all that stuff much of
which can be done without a complete
product so that's that's really
important i would say the next thing is
to surround yourself with incredible
people
um
and be that people in your company
as we've talked earlier about your your
venture capital investors and i'd
encourage all you guys that are starting
companies not just to get venture
capital great venture capitalists and
great employees
um
but also to get somebody else on your
board than an investor some outside
person who has wonderful industry
experience
and who might like to share that
i encourage all my companies to have an
independent director and that's just
been invaluable so there's a couple
things about money
i have money well
um
yeah
we've talked about um raising money from
from the best venture capitals you can
in the early days and don't worry about
getting the best price until later and
this whole thing of keeping your runway
clear and until you're
sure that you're not going to have to
sell for 80 million bucks you don't want
to raise too much money
you've said that finding customers is
the hardest thing to do right now and
i've seen an awful lot of really good
startups on paper they even have a good
prototype of their product but they
can't break through all that noise out
there there is so much noise
especially in the consumer sphere of
branding and marketing out there
that
it seems almost impossible
to get enough customers why don't do
consumer deals yeah no i mean
i i saw reed hoffman a couple months ago
and he said you know to be frank if we
were trying to start linkedin right now
we would fail
because we did it when there wasn't a
lot of noise out there
yeah yeah but mara hershenson's right
here in the audience and she has a bunch
of consumer deals that are doing
incredible
and so how do you rise above the noise i
don't know
i
have mark come up here
um i i do think i mean of course you
have to have great stuff but that's not
and you know i think there's an element
of luck an element of style
um
i think it's risky business
how do you get the right you talked
about you want to get people with
experience
uh on your board how do you get them i
mean if you go to a venture capital firm
these days a lot of them are so bloated
with you know
people that are younger than you
you know i mean people people are just
out of college and they're they're
getting they're
getting enormous responsibility and
there's always that former ceo sitting
there somewhere in that firm how do you
get his or her attention how do you get
that expertise that wisdom well i don't
think you get it from a venture capital
firm i mean occasionally you do you can
find a venture capitalist who had a
great operating experience but even
still you want to counterbalance that so
so i think you
uh as a founder of a company you sort of
make a list of the 20 guys you admire
most in the business and cold call them
or cold
test them or whatever um
go make it happen
pick them out and you know you'd be
surprised you find somebody who's i
don't know in their late 30s has had a
successful startup maybe they're still
working at it
you'd be surprised how interesting it is
for people like that to sit on a board
particularly if they're not on a board
so they don't have to be like
professional board sitters
um and it's great advice for you and
it's great kind of counterbalance to the
venture capitalists because they're not
always right so it's nice to have a guy
who's like
independent
and good
before we run out of time when you look
back on your career what are you proud
of stuff
well in the venture capital side of it
i'm i'm really proud that i did right by
my investors my investors were all
university endowments foundations and a
few pension funds
and so that uh
you know
ninety percent irr
actually our funds the the the all the
funds i've been active in were returned
six to eight times so huge irrs for
those so i'm really proud of that for
the investors
and uh i got to have the fun of creating
some great companies with some amazing
people and and of course now in my
dotage
so a bunch of those ceos are like my
personal friends and that's just really
that's a gift now it seems to me that
you've found a balance
if i had asked you 15 years ago someone
said how's catherine does she have a
good life balance i would say i don't
know she's always in the office but now
i visualize you at the ranch you know
walking among the grapevines checking
out the crush
you know and and more than that you
became a philanthropist i mean at one
point
weren't you the the world's leading
supporter of original classic music i
was of composers composers yeah i did
that for a while and uh yeah but i mean
i'm retired now i'm i'm i have great
yeah how many days are you in in the
valley per week
no
uh seriously i'm here like every other
week maybe okay you know how many
companies are you uh watching right now
i'm not not zero zero but i'm working
with the three uh micro vcs and so i
visit them and
is that when you find the balance you
find it after your career i think so as
far as i know yeah so i you know i i
have a good life on all that right now
what advice do you give to the young
women in this audience okay i really
want you to i really want you to address
that you mentioned the term the you've
said it's valuable to be oblivious
yeah i really want to know what that
means
okay so so for you women um
we kind of skipped over the fact that i
was at merrell pickard an old line
venture firm and then in the mid 90s
started um foundation capital
and the reason i started foundation
capital was that i couldn't get a job so
um
and by then my track record i was
already well on the way to this ninety
percent irr had a bunch of great
companies um
so
uh
but my merrell picker blew up and um
andy ratcliffe some of you may know and
bruce dunleavy went off to form with
some other guys benchmark capital and i
went off eventually to form
foundation capital
but before i did that i i thought
maybe i'll just go like join an existing
firm but i was kind of picky there was
only a large handful of firms that i
would have joined
and i went and started talking to those
guys mind you with this track record
and it was like
i i spent maybe three months doing that
and it was clear that it was going to
take like a really long time and so this
is the only time in my career that that
i feel like
i reached a wall because i was a woman
because if i'd been a guy
i am sure that i would have been snapped
up really quickly um
and so i was like i'm not going to
spend a year doing this because you know
i was right in the middle of this i had
all these companies and i was on all
these boards all these companies going
public left and right and i had you know
lots of good things happening and i
didn't want to spend a year kind of
looking for a job
so i i decided well hell i'll just um
start a firm so
so i started my firm and hooked up with
a couple other people who were loose in
the business and we started the firm and
um
and so i had the money raised you know
in a few months and
and now as it turns out it's kind of a
sour grape sounding thing but i loved it
i was so glad that i got to start my own
firm and do things my way and it was
great and um
almost all of our investors our original
investors were investors uh in my
previous firm so they knew me
and so that part wasn't hard in fact of
endowments and foundations those kind of
entities a goodly number of the chief
investment officers of those companies
are women so raising money was no
problem but there was this weird thing
about venture capital
and all male firms and if you look
around the valley even now there are
very few
high-level women that have gone into
those all-male firms i think like mary
meeker
has done it at kleiner but she's amazing
and there aren't i can't i have a hard
time thinking of too many more
um so what is oblivious oh movies oh
yeah so
so i sit with steve blake a couple weeks
ago going
steve
i've had like this whole woman thing is
like maybe blown out of proportion
because i've had absolutely no problems
in my life it's just been great except
for that once you know exception um and
he says no catherine
the problem with you is you're oblivious
i'm like oh
and
uh i would say being oblivious is a
great strategy for women just forget
about it just plow right through those
walls and don't think about it because
if you sit there and dwell on oh god you
don't know is he not listening to me
because i'm a woman
or because i suck better to assume that
it's because you suck and you've got to
clean it up then to assume that you're a
woman because that's just kind of a
loser attitude anyway so uh be oblivious
it's a good plan
work for me
what if you discover you suck and you
need to clean it up what do you got to
do you talk about introspection but you
talked about demeanor and and man oh
yeah
yeah it is important to have
i mean i think most of you women here
get this you have to have like the right
demeanor you don't want to be having
guys flirting with you
um and stuff but i really believe that
if you
carry yourself in the right way that's
not going to happen i just i i can't
even imagine what about that what about
the deadly g word gravitas yeah right i
think it's important to develop that and
you probably get that from developing
your sales skills i don't know
but
there's maybe there i don't know maybe
there should be some lessons on that
because i actually think that's
important for women because people do
scrutinize you more than they scrutinize
a man and they're looking for
the negative ones are looking for sort
of cracks in your demeanor and um or
signs of weakness or signs of feminine
things or you know afraid they might
make you cry or some like that so
you know
you should there should maybe be some
demeanor lessons i don't know ladies and
gentlemen i want to thank you the
singular katherine girls i'm sorry
you